speaking with ABC News on Wednesday
night President Trump said that he would
like to resume the use of waterboarding
stating that it works and that we have
to fight fire with fire
but he acknowledged that he would follow
the lead of CIA director Mike Pompeo and
defense secretary James Madison who
opposed the use of waterboarding Trump
said if they don't want to do that's
fine if they do want to do then that
will work toward that end
I want to do everything within the
bounds of what you're legally allowed to
do but do I feel it works absolutely I
feel it works
Pompeyo has already stated that he would
absolutely not comply with in order to
waterboard the media predictably have
gone insane how could Trump say the
torture works well first of all it's
actually unclear whether waterboarding
is torture some people find it to be
self-evidently torture but as Senator
Ted Cruz said during the primaries under
the law torture is excruciating pain
that is equivalent to losing organs and
systems this is enhanced interrogation
it is vigorous interrogation that does
not meet the generally recognized
definition of torture I've actually
watched my friend steven crowder get
waterboarded it looks highly unpleasant
and Stevens an idiot and that's for
doing it but he emerged not only
unscathed but he actually joked during
the experience waterboarding is used
regularly to Train Navy SEALs then
there's the second question is Trump
right does waterboarding work James
Mitchell a former chief CIA interrogator
wrote in The Wall Street Journal last
year quote it is understandable the
general mattis would say he never found
waterboarding useful because no one in
the military has been authorized to
waterboard a detainee thousands of US
military personnel have been
waterboarded as part of their training
though the services eventually abandon
the practice after finding it too
effective in getting even the most
hardened warrior to reveal critical
information
Mitchell claims that the Khalid Sheikh
Mohammed the man behind the 9/11 attacks
a crucial source of American information
about al-qaeda only broke because of
waterboarding KSM was waterboarded 783
times crowded by the way was
waterboarded several times just during
the session that I watched by way of
contrast Jose Rodriguez who once headed
the CIA national clandestine service has
claimed that terrorist mastermind Abu
Zubaydah also gave up key intelligence
after being waterboarded in the medians
are in the media's ardent desire to
paint Donald Trump as a nutty dictator
in Waiting they've actually made Trump
more popular again Trump isn't saying
anything that Americans don't believe a
poll from last March showed that almost
2/3 of Americans thought waterboarding
was appropriate for you some suspects
only 15% of Americans thought
waterboarding should be ruled out
entirely Trump has his finger on the
pulse of Americans when it comes to
rhetoric about fighting terrorism
the media's overstated outrage only
makes it clear why Americans trust Trump
to fight terrorism rather than the
members of the press I'm Ben Shapiro
this is the Ben Shapiro show all righty
so we can jump right in today and we
begin with Donald Trump's immigration
executive order so Trump has jumped in
with alacrity he clearly wants to
fulfill this promise now I actually
thought that he would fulfill some of
his promises on immigration I still I'm
not sure that the deportations are gonna
look like what he said they were gonna
look like during the campaign but the
executive order that he signed yesterday
makes it look like he is actually going
to be just as harsh on illegal
immigration as he promised to be during
the campaign so I want to go through
this executive order and talk about what
exactly was in it yesterday so first of
all it said that we're gonna build the
wall when the Trump himself and I came
out and he said this he was speaking at
the Department of Homeland Security and
he suggested that we're building the
wall it's definitely going to happen
when does construction begin as soon as
we can as soon as we can physically do
it we're okay months I would say in
months yeah I would say in life
certainly planning is starting
immediately and so he says that we're
gonna pay for that with Mexican money he
that's more vague how we're gonna
actually do that honestly I always
thought that was a silly part of his
promise I don't care how we pay for a
barrier between the United States and
Mexico it seems to me a perfectly
eminently rational thing to have some
sort of touch fence some sort of barrier
that prevents people from simply walking
over the border without any sort of
detection mechanism in place at all
Israel has a very effective border
there's no reason why exactly the United
States should not want to have one at
the southern border either also with
Mexico has some physical borders at its
southern border because it doesn't like
illegal immigration again I don't see
why the United States should be the only
country in the world that's not allowed
to have one of these things I've said
that all along
Trump was speaking at the DHS and his
rhetoric about enforcement with regard
to illegal immigration I think is just
first-rate here he is because people are
surprised to hear that we do not need
new laws we will work within the
existing system
and framework and he said also that he's
going to ask the members of DHS to
enforce the laws to their fullest extent
this clip one I'm asking all of you to
enforce the laws of the United States of
America they will be enforced and
enforced strongly we are going to
restore the rule of law in the United
States a nation without borders is not a
nation beginning today the United States
of America gets back control of its
borders gets back its borders you guys
are about to be very very busy doing
your job the way you want to do them ok
and this is the kind of rhetoric that I
think is actually useful with regard to
border enforcement so good for Trump on
all of this now there are a couple of
questions about the executive orders
themselves first question is why he's
using executive orders and not just
passing a law with Congress there's
gonna have to be some sort of
congressional appropriation to build the
wall it's gonna cost something like
fifteen billion dollars to build the
wall the left of course is up in arms
about all of this they're saying that
they're very upset about the spending
which is ridiculous since the left has
never been upset about spending on
anything ever in fact I'm old enough to
remember when the left liked
infrastructure spending right this is an
infrastructure spending bill it just be
an infrastructure spending bill to build
a physical barrier with the
with with Mexico now the physical
barrier by the way is not just designed
to keep out quote-unquote Mexicans
because the fact is that right now or
we're neutral in terms of the number of
Mexicans coming in and leaving in the
United States via illegal immigration
we've actually had a net decline in the
number of Mexican illegal immigrants
over the past few years but what Mexico
really right now is a giant thoroughfare
for people who are coming from South
America and Central America in order to
get to the United States it's it's not
really about Mexicans crossing the
border even though Trump seems to get
that wrong pretty routinely it's more
about people who are coming from places
like El Salvador and Honduras and in
various countries in South America and
who are using Mexico as basically a
giant road to get to the north Paul Ryan
says Trump says that he's going to spend
the term says he's going to do this well
we'll give him the money
do it who's gonna pay for it well first
off we're going to pay for it in front
the money up but I do think that there
are various ways of as you know I know
your follow-up question is is Mexico
gonna pay for the wall there are a lot
of different ways of getting Mexico to
contribute to doing this now I'm gonna
get to how Mexico contributes to doing
this and why this is still a silly
talking point it always was a silly
talking point they get to that in a
second first I want to go through the
actual content of the executive order by
the way the ACLU just demonstrates how
crazy they are they say that the wall
violates civil liberties they tweeted
out the executive order president Trump
just signed funding wall along our
southern border violates civil liberties
hashtag no ban no wall no it doesn't
violate civil liberties that's plainly
silly and then why exactly would it
violate civil liberties to build a wall
on an internationally recognized border
six thing it violates civil liberties to
build a fence around your house whose
civil liberties the person who wants to
break into my house now that's not the
way this works now as far as the
executive order itself this would be a
perfectly legal executive order because
it exists within the confines of laws
that have already been passed by
Congress in 2006 Congress said that they
wanted to build a border fence when they
didn't fully fund it so Trump is not
doing anything that is outside the
confines of legislation that he is now
using the legislation in order to push
the policy that's what an executive
order is supposed to do the reason that
I opposed Barack Obama's executive
orders is because many of them just
rewrote the law plainly right he just
went in and rewrote Obama care for
example or he won and he rewrote
immigration law with regard to daca and
DAPA that's not what Trump is doing here
Trump is saying and he said it as he saw
at DHS he said that at Homeland Security
he said clearly this is the existing law
we're acting within the existing law and
that's exactly right so what exactly is
in this executive order so in this
executive order he talks about
broadening enforcement priorities as
well so it used to be that Barack Obama
only wanted to police crimes that were
committed other than crossing the border
illegally section 5c of this executive
order now grants the Secretary of
Homeland Security power to prioritize
for removal those who have committed
acts that constitute a chargeable
criminal offense you don't have to be
convicted it's just if you cross the
border illegally and we have reason to
believe you cross the border illegally
you've committed acts that constitute
and a chargeable offense you cross the
border illegally we can
now enforce the law against you this
also takes priority to to false use of a
social security number or taking public
benefits illegally the the order also
grants the Secretary of Homeland
Security the ability to hire 10,000
additional law enforcement officers that
number really should be 20,000 I believe
the 20,000 was the number in the in that
horrifying gang of eight bill even so
that number needs to be increased the
executive order allows states to help
police immigration so you remember the
Obama administration sued the state of
Arizona because the state of Arizona had
the temerity to try and enforce
immigration law and Barack Obama then
tried to sue them for that Oh Trump is
is saying now that he wants states to be
allowed to do that that they should be
allowed to help perform the functions of
immigration officers in relation to
investigation apprehension detention of
aliens in the United States so he's not
banning States from actually helping
enforce federal law this also kills
funding to sanctuary cities that's a
little bit of a complicated question
because the question is what strings you
can attach to funding to particular
cities or states it's actually a complex
constitutional question can you just
withdraw funding from every program in
San Francisco because you don't like
what they're doing with illegal
immigrants probably not you actually
have to find the funding that is
connected to immigration enforcement in
San Francisco and then cut off that
funding there has to be some sort of
rational relation between the grants the
federal government is giving to a city
or a state and the and the acts that the
city or state is doing constitutionally
just in terms of Supreme Court
jurisprudence but Trump is attempting to
do this the executive order also creates
a public shaming capacity for the feds
so every week they're going to make a
public list of criminal actions
committed by illegal aliens and any
jurisdiction that ignored or failed to
otherwise honor federal law fifth this
is going to restore the Secure
Communities program so originally the
Obama administration had a program that
allowed the feds to check immigration
databases to see local offenders who
were here illegally then they walked
that back they didn't want the feds to
be able to check the local criminal
databases for purposes of deporting
people who were arrested locally Trump
is returning to the original system
which is a great thing also he's saying
that he wants to make foreign
negotiations contingent on accepting
repatriated legal immigrants so if
Poland has an illegal immigrant and they
don't want to accept that illegal
immigrant background I'm not going to
negotiate with Poland I'm going to tell
the Secretary of State not
negotiations with countries that don't
accept back the illegal immigrants that
are coming over here and finally he
wants to make data more transparent so
right now one of the big problems with
the illegal immigration ban Coulter
points this out in her book about
illegal immigration which is actually a
very interesting book there's a lot it's
not in God it's not in Trump We Trust
which is not a particularly interesting
book it's it's it's her book about its
book her I've interviewed her on c-span
we did it actually her book about
illegal immigration which is really
interesting she points out that the data
on illegal immigration and crime among
the illegal immigrants is really
incredibly weak and this would make that
data more transparent now the Secretary
of Homeland Security and Attorney
General can collect data on immigration
status of all aliens incarcerated in
federal prisons as well as federal
pretrial detainees and all convicted
aliens in state and local prisons so all
of this stuff is good this is a very
good executive order there's a lot here
that's good there are rumors today that
Trump was gonna sign some sort of order
repealing daca and DAPA getting rid of
President Obama's executive amnesty this
is a I'm not sure that you actually have
to do that but he hasn't done that yet
again I want to see what this looks like
in practice is he going to go back to
enforcing law or is this all cover for
basically not doing particularly a lot
that's not that's not clear yet that'll
only become clear in the enforcement but
the executive order itself is really
first-rate there's a lot here that is
really really good okay so putting that
aside now Donald Trump did an interview
on ABC News that's getting all sorts of
play as well and Donald Trump's
interview with ABC News there were some
good and there was some bad so you know
now's a perfect time we can play the
good trump bad Trump let's do it
[Music]
okay so we begin with some good trim so
Trump had a lot of good things to say
during this particular interview with
ABC News so he started off by talking
about the media bias and when Trump hits
the media and it's justifiable I love it
it's my favorite thing in the world I've
been saying for literally years that
Republicans ought to smack the media
when the media does something wrong I
don't like it when they smack the media
on the media actually is telling the
truth and we'll get to that in a second
but I like when they smack the media for
doing things that are wrong so the media
for years has ignored the March for Life
in Washington DC the March for Life
routinely means hundreds of thousands of
people marching in the streets of
Washington DC in the middle of dead
winter in order to march in favor of
legislation that would restrict
abortions and the killing of the unborn
and the media every year ignores it it
always goes on page a 12 of the New York
Times Donald Trump is talking with David
mirror and he rightly this is great he
smacks David Muir for not covering the
march for life we know there were more
than a million people who turned out and
you are their president now - that's
true could you hear them from the whales
I couldn't hear them but the crowds were
large but you didn't have a large crowd
on Friday - which is mostly pro-life
people you're gonna have a lot of people
coming to Friday and I will say this and
I didn't realize this but I was told you
will have a very large crowd of people I
don't know as large or larger some
people so it's going to be larger
pro-life people and they say the press
doesn't cover them I don't want to
compare crowds I know you should let me
just say what they do say is that the
press doesn't cover them and that's a
hundred percent true he's totally right
to smack David mirror on this the fact
that the press covers this women's march
up the wazoo that happened one time the
Marshall life happens every single year
and every single year the media ignores
it good for Donald Trump that is a
tunnelled Trump at his finest Donald
Trump also talked about torture we
talked about this at the very beginning
here's Donald Trump had to say about
torture are you sir are you at all
concerned it's going to cause more I
will tell you I have spoken to others in
intelligence and they are big believers
in as an example waterboarding you do
tell they say it does work it does work
mr. president Ursula mr. president you
told me during one of the debates that
you
bring back waterboarding and a hell of a
lot worse fire do or I would do I want
to keep our country safe I want to keep
our country safe I'm going with general
mattis I'm going with my secretary
because I think Pompeo is going to be
phenomenal I'm gonna go with what they
say but I have spoken as recently as 24
hours ago
with people at the highest level of
intelligence and I asked them the
question does it work does torture work
and the answer is yes absolutely
we're not playing on an even field I
will say this I will rely on Pompeo and
mattis and my group and if they don't
want to do that's fine
if they do want to do then I will work
that end I want to do everything within
the bounds of what you're allowed to do
legally but do I feel it works
absolutely I feel it works so you feel
cable I know I want to know I will rely
on general manners and I'm gonna rely on
those two people and others and if they
don't want to do it that's 100% okay
with me do I think it works absolutely
okay so I have no problem with anything
the Trump just said there in fact as we
spoke about a little bit earlier on the
program the fact is that there are a lot
of people in the intelligence community
who disagree with Madison Madison
doesn't have a lot of experience with
waterboarding since he was at Department
of Defense he was not at CIA so good for
a good for Donald Trump here I don't
think there's any problem with anything
that Donald Trump just said with regard
to this okay now we get to some bad
Trump unfortunately unfortunately I wish
that every day we're good Trump nothing
but good Trump and I will say that I
think 75% of the stuff he's done is good
I think 25% of the stuff he's done is
bad I think 80% of the stuff he says is
silly and I think 20% is good so if you
just pay attention to what he does that
what he does he's doing a lot of really
good stuff if you pay attention to what
he says okay so he so on Twitter he has
decided that you know he can't just say
we're building the wall and I'm keeping
my promise
instead he feels the necessity to smack
around Mexico a little bit more so he
tweets the US has a sixty billion dollar
trade deficit with Mexico it has been a
one-sided deal from the beginning of
NAFTA with massive numbers of jobs and
companies lost if Mexico is unwilling to
pay for
badly-needed wall then it would be
better to cancel the upcoming meeting so
in other words he's now connecting NAFTA
which he hates with the with the wall
and he's saying that if you're not gonna
pay for the wall that I'm gonna cave in
them and destroy NAFTA also I hate NAFTA
anyway NAFTA terrible so a few things to
talk about here one who cares whether
Mexico quote unquote pays for the wall
who really like really why is that a big
deal
whether Mexican I understand there's
this vindictive need to make Mexico pay
for the wall and all of this but it's
not that much money it really isn't and
I just want the thing built and Trump is
getting himself into ancillary issues
that don't matter because of all this we
have to make Mexico pay for the wall so
Mexico naturally they came they came for
and they said fine we'll cancel the
upcoming meeting we don't have to have a
meeting you want to cancel NAFTA you go
right ahead and do it but we don't have
to have that meeting when he talks about
the the trade deficits and all this a
couple quick points of information one
trade deficits don't matter trade
deficits do not matter you have a trade
deficit with every store you buy from
does that mean you shouldn't buy from
those stores doesn't make you poor
because you're buying from a place that
you want to buy from of course not we
all have personal trade deficits with a
bevy of players out there does that mean
that we are suddenly poor no it doesn't
mean that it means that you're engaged
in voluntary trade the supposed trade
deficit with Mexico just means that
we're buying lots of product from Mexico
and that a lot of the money that we're
investing in Mexico is coming back to us
in the form of capital surplus it's
called capital account surplus we can't
spend American dollars in Mexico and so
they're gonna have to use those out
those dollars someplace the big problem
that we have regarded trade deficits is
not the trade deficit itself it's that
the government keeps raising debt and
raising debt by selling bonds so what
happens is that we end up selling bonds
so what happens is that there's a trade
deficit with Mexico now they have a
surplus of dollars instead of taking
that surplus of dollars and investing in
American businesses which is normally
what happens instead of doing that
they're taking those dollars and they're
buying US debt so that's yeah the big
problem there is the government as
always the problem is the government as
far as the idea that NAFTA has made us
poorer that's absolute nonsense the fact
is that NAFTA has made a significantly
richer because all of the jobs that fled
to Mexico all of those and more would
have fled to China the reason that
there's this regional North American
trade bloc in which people invest is be
you can make a car partially in Mexico
ship that same car up to Jackson up to
Jackson Mississippi and then you can
take that and then you can take that car
and sell it at a warehouse in California
all right the point is that we have a
physically contiguous territory
with Mexico we don't with China so if
you're going to if you're a car
manufacturer you would prefer to be able
to find cheap labor on the continent it
cuts down on shipping cost it allows you
to actually put factories that are
slightly more expensive in the United
States if they had to produce all this
stuff in China instead of building
another factory in the United States and
shipping it between Mexico in the United
States instead of doing that they would
build the stuff in China ship it to
Korea and then maybe ship it out to the
United States yes you create jobs
because of all of this even in the
manufacturing sector that wouldn't
otherwise exist
it's actually really short-sighted
economically to look at to look at NAFTA
this way there hasn't been this giant
sucking sound taking jobs that would
have stayed in America except for NAFTA
those jobs were leaving anyway because
they were very expensive jobs Mex is
just going to Mexico because Mexico is
nearest to the United States plus if
Donald Trump actually wants to cut down
on illegal immigration the worst way to
cut down on illegal immigration it turns
out is to destroy the economy of our
southern neighbor if you want an
unstable Mexico like even more unstable
than it is now if you want Mexico
completely unstable with a crappy
economy and you think that's gonna have
no impact on the number of people
rushing to get through the border you're
out of your mind
it'll take years to build this thing by
the way so it's not like tomorrow the
border is secure it's gonna take a while
if you destroy the economy of Mexico at
the same time you're hurting the economy
of the United States that's really
really dumb so this is bad Trump it's
very silly and again there's no reason
for doing this other than Trump has
these misperceptions that become policy
and this is one of the problems for
Trump sometimes he comes up with good
policy based on bad ideas based on bad
rationales we'll talk about that more in
a second plus we have the mailbag coming
up in order to see the rest you're gonna
have to go over to daily wired.com and
check us out over there eight bucks a
month we'll get you a subscription to
daily wire comm if you want an annual
subscription then go over to daily wire
coming you can still get a free signed
copy of my book you become part of the
mailbag so we do the live mailbag in
just a few minutes here so you can go
over to daily wire subscribe right now
continue watching the episode within
minutes you could be asking your
question to me
making your life significantly better in
every conceivable way so go to daily
wire comm right now and subscribe or you
can listen later at iTunes and
SoundCloud make sure you subscribe at
iTunes you can leave a review at iTunes
as well we always appreciate that you
are listening to the number one
conservative podcast in the United
States
[Music]
you